hiding my feelings for many years,
but I couldn't give
up
anyway, and I thought that there was nothing I could do about it, but I
couldn't hide it, and
I was so worried that this happened to me.  I
'm
[Music]
The truth is, I'm a woman who punched her when her boyfriend confessed to me, but I'm hiding it.
Even if I have feelings of cancer, the worst I can
do is get hit, so it's okay.
[Music]
Well,
I love you.  A
long time ago
[Music] I
heard ``Sorry, wait, I like you,'' but it just happened.What's the point in
dumping my dear friend?I'm confused.Or
rather, didn't you understand this flow?
Well, what should I say?  I wonder if you
like me
[Music]
Because, you know, I
felt like you were really nice to me,
so that's not true.
[Music]
Tegome-
chan,
I'm the one who can't say it all the time
[Music]
I forgive you